[Musik]
am 19 märz
1945 erteilt adolf hitler eine order die
als nero befehl in die geschichte
eingeht
die zerstörungs maßnahmen im
reichsgebiet ermächtigten die deutschen
truppen alles zu zerstören das dem feind
nützen konnte also zum beispiel brücken
strassen industrie und
infrastrukturanlagen
zum glück ignorierten die meisten
deutschen kommandeure diesen befehl
sonst wäre deutschland komplett zerstört
worden doch genau darum geht es hitler
am tag bevor hitler den befehl gab sagte
er zu albert speer wenn der krieg
verloren geht wird auch das volk
verloren sein
das deutsche volk hatte sich in seinen
augen weil es besiegt wurde als das
schwächere erwiesen
deswegen verdiente es vernichtet zu
werden
hitler war wie ihn seine eigenen
wagner-oper gefangen er stürzte
deutschland in die götterdämmerung
absolut narzisstischer
aktiv wenn hitler untergeht muss die
nation die seine ansprüche nicht erfüllt
hat mit ihm untergehen
ein letzter rundumschlag der alles
zerstören soll
klar ist hitler nicht der einzige
auf der anderen seite der erde hat sich
der japanische generalstab vorgenommen
bis zum bitteren ende zu kämpfen
egal um welchen preis
wie groß müsste die zerstörung seien um
sie von dieser denkweise abzubringen
selbst in der stunde der niederlage sind
die männer die diesen krieg begonnen
haben entschlossen ihr eigenes volk zu
opfern
[Musik]
zwischen dem 24
juli und dem dritten august 1943
verwandeln über 2.300 west alliierte
bomber die eineinhalb millionen stadt
hamburg in ein flammendes inferno
bei der operation gomorrha wurde am
beispiel von hamburg durchexerziert wie
mit hilfe von brandbomben ein moderner
strategischer bombenkrieg geführt werden
kann
die nur vier angriffswellen warfen die
alliierten um die 9000 tonnen bomben ab
bis zu 45.000 menschen starben drei
viertel der stadt wurden zerstört und
knapp eine million einwohner wurden
obdachlos
nach der operation gomorrha sagte albert
speer angeblich zu hitler noch sechs
solcher angriffe und das war's die nazis
hatten glück 1943 fehlen den briten noch
die kapazitäten für viele solcher
angriffe
das ändert sich 1944 als den alliierten
neuer flugzeugtyp zur verfügung steht
ein jagdflugzeug die north american p 51
mustang
und der wichtigste neuzugang für den
bombenkrieg der alliierten war die
mustang sie waren langstrecken begleit
flugzeug und konnte es mit jedem
kampfflieger im luftraum über
deutschland aufnehmen
sie wurde von einem rolls royce merlin
motor angetrieben und besaß eine
überragende flugleistung ihre bewaffnung
bestand aus sechs kaliber 50
maschinengewehren schlagkräftige waffen
für tiefflieger und abfang mission
sie war mit langstrecken tanks
ausgerüstet die abgeworfen werden
konnten wenn sie leer waren 16 so kam
sie auf eine reichweite von bis zu 3300
kilometern und konnte alliierte bomber
bis nach deutschland und zurück
begleiten
bis zum ende des krieges werden mehr als
15.000 p 51 mustang hergestellt die
verluste alliierter bomber fallen von 10
auf 3,5 prozent
die flächenbombardements der alliierten
setzen den deutschen städten massiv zu
in den letzten eineinhalb jahren des
krieges werden über 40 mal mehr bomben
auf deutsche ziele abgeworfen als von
den deutschen auf politische ziele
während der luftschlacht um england
auch städte wie dresden essen köln
bremen und berlin werden ziele so
genannter tausend bomber angriffe die
verluste unter der zivilbevölkerung sind
verheerend
sie wussten dass sie einige ungeschützte
ziele finden mussten sie wählten
kommunikationszentren chemiefabriken und
raffinerien
es waren strategisch wichtige orte aber
dort lebten auch viele zivilisten durch
die flächenbombardements wurden sie oft
vollkommen zerstört war es
gerechtfertigt so viele menschen zu
töten um deutschlands kampfkraft zu
schwächen
eine untersuchung der alliierten die
direkt nach kriegsende durchgeführt
wurde ergab dass weniger als 17 prozent
der deutschen industrie anlagen von
bomben zerstört wurden
albert speer hatte die lage anders
eingeschätzt
wer behauptet dass dem deutschen militär
aufgrund der bombardierungen 35 prozent
weniger panzer 31 prozent weniger
flugzeuge und 42 prozent weniger lkw zur
verfügung standen
flugabwehrgeschütze machten ein drittel
der gesamten artillerie produktion aus
drei viertel der 8,8 cm kanonen die
deutschland besaß mussten für die
flugabwehr eingesetzt werden und fehlten
deshalb an der ostfront und bei der
verteidigung der normandie
es war die effektivste allzweckwaffe
über die deutschland verfügt
1944 änderte die achte us luftflotte
ihre strategie zitat ab jetzt alles
dafür um die versorgung der deutschen
streitkräfte mit öl zu unterbinden und
um ihre kommunikation zu stören und das
so effektiv dass die deutsche
kriegswirtschaft nicht mehr richtig
funktionierte ab nun hat der bombenkrieg
einen spürbaren einfluss auf die
deutschen kriegs anstrengungen das
bestätigt albert speer auch adolf hitler
hatte die produktion in deutschland
zwischen 1941 und 43 verdreifacht
er kam zu dem schluss dass die deutsche
kriegswirtschaft den schaden durch die
alliierten bombardements nicht
kompensieren konnte
der luftkrieg kostet in deutschland bis
zu 600.000 zivilisten das leben
ob das ergebnis des luftkriegs die
schrecklich hohe zahl ziviler opfer
rechtfertigt muss jeder für sich selbst
beurteilen
dezember 1944 die alliierten haben erst
ein drittel ihrer bomben über
deutschland abgeworfen
adolf hitler eine großoffensive um den
vormarsch der briten und amerikaner von
westen zu stoppen
am 16 dezember nähern sich die
alliierten streitkräfte deutschland
sie sind erschöpft aber das oberkommando
ist darüber nicht besorgt da es in der
gegend keinen feind vermutet doch der
geheimdienste alliierten hat sich
getäuscht in den wäldern der ardennen
liegen 17 deutsche divisionen auf der
lauer darunter fünf panzerdivisionen
alles in allem um die
240.000 mann und sie haben einige tiger
zwei panzer dabei
das ist der tiger zwei auch königstiger
genannt seine front panzerung ist 18 5
zentimeter dick
dieses gesetz ist eine 8,8 cm kampfwagen
kann ohne die alliierten hatten die auf
dem schlachtfeld nichts entgegenzusetzen
hitler wollte so viele wie möglich davon
haben aber ihre herstellung war
aufwendig und dauerte lange
am morgen des 16 dezember starten die
deutschen einen überraschungsangriff auf
die sechs geschwächten
83.000 mann starken usd visionen
[Musik]
die ardennenoffensive deutscher deckname
wacht am rhein schlägt eine 60 kilometer
breite ausbuchtung in die reihen der
west alliierten streitkräfte am anfang
der schlacht sieht es so aus als ob sich
die deutschen nach entwerten
durchschlagen können noch kurz vor
weihnachten ändert sich die lage
ein schwachpunkt im plan der deutschen
ist die versorgung mit treibstoff
dieser panzer schluckt jede menge sprit
mit vollem tank kommt der ungefähr 170
kilometer weit doch dann braucht man 860
liter benzin um wieder voll zu tanken
damals lag die ration für einen
deutschen panzer bei 15 litern pro tag
wenn es ein panzer also nicht ans ziel
schaffte liebe einfach irgendwo stehen
das ziel ist die belgische staatsbahn
nahe der deutschen grenze in
spa wurden unmengen an treibstoff
gelagert buchstäblich am straßenrand
eine deutsche aufklärungseinheit war
kurz davor das lager zu entdecken
deswegen beschlossen ein captain der
us-armee und ein paar belgische soldaten
kurzerhand mitten auf der straße einen
graben auszuheben denzin rhein zu kippen
und es anzuzünden als die
aufklärungseinheit das sah drehte sie um
und zog ab dabei waren sie kurz davor
den treibstoff zu finden der sie bis
nach antwerpen gebracht hätte
für die deutschen wird nicht nur das
benzin knapp sondern auch die zeit
sobald der himmel über ihnen aufgebaut
werden sie von alliierten jagdbombern
ins visier genommen und general patton
startete einen gegenangriff
[Musik]
die ardennenoffensive kostet hitler
knapp 100.000 mann um die 700
panzerwagen und 1600 kampfflugzeuge die
deutsche luftwaffe wird sich von den
verlusten an mensch und material nicht
mehr erholen
einige deutsche generäle hatten sich
gegen die offensive ausgesprochen weil
die truppen nützlicher gewesen wären um
berlin gegen die sowjets zu verteidigen
sie hatten sie angefordert doch hitler
wollte unbedingt die ardennenoffensive
durchführen zum antwerpen
zurückzuerobern
konkret das einzige was sie erreichten
war die alliierten auszubremsen
was war also das ergebnis der
ardennenoffensive
dass ein großteil deutschlands von der
roten armee erobert wurde
am 30 januar 1945 erreichen general
schubs forderte verbände die oder die
rote armee ist jetzt nur noch 70
kilometer von berlin entfernt ihr
vorrücken ist kaum noch aufzuhalten
doch die deutschen kämpfen weiter
zum motiv ab 1943 wiederholte die
deutsche propaganda gebetsmühlenartig
die alliierten werden vergeltung üben
die juden werden sich rächen und die
bolschewiken werden deutschland über
wollen wir manche deutsche glaubten dass
und kämpften deswegen bis zum bitteren
ende im falle der roten armee trifft ein
teil der propaganda tatsächlich zu
die sowjets gingen sehr brutal gegen die
deutsche bevölkerung vor es gibt
zahlreiche beweise für
vergeltungsmaßnahmen und plünderungen
es war ganz einfach rache die deutschen
waren äußerst brutal mit den sowjets
umgegangen
dazu kam dass der lebensstandard in
deutschland sehr viel höher war als in
der sowjetunion
ein einfacher deutscher bauer lebte
wesentlich besser als ein russischer
die sowjets konnten nicht verstehen
warum die deutschen in ihr land
eingefallen waren wenn es ihnen so gut
ging
das fachte ihre wut und ihr brutales
verhalten noch weiter an
am schlimmsten trifft es frauen
[Musik]
millionen deutscher frauen wurden von
den soldaten der roten armee
vergewaltigt viele verfügten selbstmord
bevor sie den sowjets in die hände
fielen oder nachdem sie von ihnen
missbraucht worden waren es war eine
fürchterliche rache
in den letzten fünf kriegs monaten
sterben mindestens
400.000 deutsche soldaten dabei besteht
keine hoffnung mehr auf den endsieg von
dem hitler immer noch redet manche
wollen in dieser zeit noch schnell die
spuren größter nazi-verbrechen
verwischen
am 27 januar 1945 entdeckte eine einheit
der ersten ukrainischen front der roten
armee ein lager in einem wald etwa 50
kilometer westlich von krakau
[Musik]
es war verlassen und einige der gebäude
waren zerstört worden
doch die sowjetischen soldaten fanden
noch 8000 abgemagerte menschen vor die
ihnen erklärten wo genau sie waren
in auschwitz
das kz auschwitz birkenau ist das größte
deutsche vernichtungslager
ein symbol für die grauenhaften
verbrechen die das naziregime während
des holocaust verübt hat doch es ist
nicht das einzige lager dass die sowjets
entdecken
bereits im sommer 44 waren die sowjets
auf das kz majdanek gestoßen
es war das einzige lager in dem die
alliierten noch intakte krematorien und
gaskammern vorfanden
durch den vormarsch der roten armee
waren die nazis überstürzt geflohen und
hatten keine zeit die beweise zu
vernichten in auschwitz versuchten sie
ihre spuren so gut es ging zu verwischen
decken sie zwangen die gefangenen zu
todesmärschen richtung westen durch die
verschneite landschaft sie kranken und
dem sterben liegenden ließen sie zurück
von den 714.000 kz häftlingen die im
januar 1945 noch lebten stirbt bis zum
fast die hälfte durch mordaktionen der
deutschen
als die sowjets auschwitz entdeckten
waren sie schockiert von dem
industriellen ausmaß in dem dort getötet
worden war
die briten und die amerikaner waren
skeptisch und glaubten ihnen anfangs
nicht doch als sie 1945 selbst die
konzentrationslager bergen belsen dachau
und buchenwald befreiten stellten sie
fest dass die sowjets die wahrheit
gesagt hatten
die deutschen haben unendliches unheil
angerichtet nun steht die wehrmacht vor
der letzten großen schlacht der um
berlin am montag den 16 april 1945
feiert die rote armee eine million
236.000 geschosse ab marschall schukow
führt die erste weißrussische front an
sie brauchten
2450 waggons für den transport der
granaten die an diesem tag auf berlin
abgefeuert wurden
die sowjets greifen an zwei fronten an
mit zweieinhalb millionen soldaten
6250 panzern
41.000 geschützen und
7500 flugzeugen
ihnen gegenüber stehen über
760.000 wehrmachtsoldaten mit
1500 panzern und 9000 geschützen
85.000 soldaten verteidigten berlin
selbst die hälfte waren alte männer oder
junge burschen viele davon stammen nazis
hafen sind dazu kamen noch ausländische
freiwillige der waffen ss
der rest der deutschen armee versuchte
berlin hinter sich zu lassen um sich den
westalliierten zu ergeben
kein wunder also dass schuhkauf nach
knapp zwei wochen in berlin vor dem
reichstag stand
am 30 april 1945 zwei tage nachdem
benito mussolini in italien erschossen
und öffentlich aufgehängt wurde begehen
adolf hitler und eva braun im
führerbunker selbstmord
am selben tag stürmen sowjetische
soldaten den reichstag und hissen die
rote flagge
am 2
berlin am 8 mai tritt die bedingungslose
kapitulation der wehrmacht im kraft in
der schlacht um berlin liegen die
verluste des auf jetzt bei über
350.000 man von denen fast
79.000 ihr leben verloren haben auf
deutscher seite sterben über
92.000 soldaten und 22.000 zivilisten
insgesamt gesehen zahlt er die rote
armee aber den höchsten preis
die sowjetunion mobilisierte im zweiten
weltkrieg um die 34,5 millionen menschen
davon sind etwa 11,5 millionen
umgekommen
die deutschen verloren dagegen nur halb
so viele männer in uniformen
die verluste der briten und amerikaner
machten zusammengenommen nur ein zehntel
von denen der sowjets aus
doch erst wenn man auch die zivilen
opfer dazu zählt wird das ganze ausmaß
der sowjetischen verluste klar
es ist zwar fast unmöglich genaue zahlen
dafür zu bekommen wie viele zivilisten
im zuge des unternehmens barbarossa
verhungerten erschossen oder durch
arbeit vernichtet wurden doch die
allgemein akzeptierte schätzung liegt
bei ungefähr 16 millionen
das heißt dass etwa 27 millionen sowjets
im mit stalins worten großen
vaterländischen krieg starben
von den 50 oder 60 millionen menschen
die insgesamt im zweiten weltkrieg
umgekommen sind kam also die hälfte aus
der sowjetunion
für die sowjets ist der krieg mit der
kapitulation der wehrmacht noch nicht zu
ende das gilt auch für die amerikaner
die chinesen und die japaner der krieg
in europa ist gewonnen der in pazifik-
noch nicht
ein jahr zuvor im april 1944 hatte die
kaiserliche japanische armee ihre größte
militäroffensive während des zweiten
weltkriegs gestartet sie richtet sich
nicht gegen amerika sondern gegen china
man vergisst gerne dass der zweite
weltkrieg eigentlich schon 1937 in china
begonnen hat und ob seitdem gekämpft
wurde
510.000 japanische soldaten nähmen an
der operation kino teil die auf dem
chinesischen festland durchgeführt wird
während der operation bombardierten die
japaner auch flugplätze von denen aus
die amerikaner angriffe gegen japan
flogen die japaner besetzten große teile
zentralchinas die ihnen in den letzten
sechs sieben jahren noch nicht in die
hände gefallen waren
als junkie schecks nationale volkspartei
zerfällt scheint der sieg der japaner
zum greifen nah
der erfolg von ikon nützt am ende aber
wenig denn er provoziert die bomben
offensive gegen die japanischen
hauptinsel
des bomber nutzen dafür die flugplätze
auf den marianne inselgruppe im
westpazifik die usa das einundzwanzigste
us-bomber kommando wurde von general
curtis geführt im februar 1945 erstellte
er eine liste japanischer städte und
industrieanlagen
es begann mit einer reihe von kleineren
luftangriffen die immer heftiger und
heftiger wurden
im ersten monat flogen seine flugzeuge
2700 angriffe auf tokio und yokohama
bei einem berüchtigten angriff auf tokio
starben allein über 83.000 menschen
anderthalb millionen wurden obdachlos
in 66 japanischen städten wurden 40
prozent der gebäude zerstört und acht
millionen menschen verloren ihr zuhause
doch es ist genau das was er sich
gewünscht hatte
sosehr erfolg auch unter diesen
angriffen leidet die japanische
regierung ist entschlossen
weiterzukämpfen
sie wollen das erkämpfte reich nicht
aufgeben
der entschlossenheit trotz der heftigen
bombardierungen weiterzukämpfen steckt
eiskaltes kalkül denn die japaner wollen
die amerikaner davon überzeugen dass
eine inversion sie teuer zu stehen käme
und dass sie deshalb von ihrer forderung
einer bedingungslosen kapitulation
abrücken würden
da die japaner sich weigern aufzugeben
starten die amerikaner die strategie des
island hopping zu deutsch insel
springens sie wollten jede von den
japanern besetzte insel auf dem weg zu
den japanischen hauptinseln einnehmen
darunter auch die strategisch wichtige
vulkan insel iwo jima
iwo jima ist drei mal kleiner als
manhattan aber es war eine wichtige
insel weil sie auf halbem wege zwischen
den drei luft stützpunkten auf den
marianen und tokio lag
sie lag genau auf der flugroute der
amerikanischen bombe auf dem weg nach
japan
hier gab es flugpisten von denen aus die
japaner die us bomber 1000 kilometer vor
tokio abfangen konnten die amerikaner
wollten diese flugplätze ausschalten
doch das ist nicht so einfach auf
die ultima gab es ein labyrinth gut
befestigter bunker und gefecht
stellungen sie hatten sich dort so gut
verschanzt dass selbst die 79 tage
andauernde bombardierung kaum schaden
angerichtet hatte
diese insel forderte unzählige tote die
amerikanischen gis müssen die stellungen
teilweise im nahkampf mit flammenwerfern
und handgranaten erobern
die schlacht um china war so heftig dass
die marines den hügeln und tälern namen
wie fleischwolf todes joch odertal des
blutes gaben
im glauben den feind endlich besiegt zu
haben richtete die us armee dort einen
stützpunkt für kampfflugzeuge ein selbst
dann kamen noch 300 japaner aus höhlen
gekrochen und überfielen die bodencrew
eroberung iwo jima es dauert 45 tage und
kostet 6 1821 us marines das leben über
18.000 werden verwundet
es war das einzige mal dass die
gesamtverluste der amerikanischen
streitkräfte höher waren als die der
japaner deren verluste bei über 21.000
anlagen
dass island hopping war von anfang an
vergleichbar mit einem schmutzigen
häuserkampf
iwo jima gibt aber nur einen
vorgeschmack auf die schlacht um okinawa
die fünf tage später beginnt
die insel war wichtig für die amerikaner
weil sie als tor zu den japanischen
hauptinseln geld würden sie optimale
einnehmen hätten sie einen stützpunkt
der nur gut 500 kilometer von den
japanischen hauptinseln entfernt ist am
ersten april
1945 ermöglichen mehr als 1.300 us
schiffe die landung von 60.000 marines
auf der insel sie sind nur die vorhut
für eine streitmacht von über
180.000 mann
sie erwarteten einen kugelhagel doch als
die landungsschiffe den stand erreichten
und die marines und soldaten an land
gingen herrschte absolute stille
sie stießen auf keinerlei gegenwehr erst
als sie zum mitte der insel kamen und
erkannten sie dass sie erwartete
plötzlich eröffnen die japaner aus
versteckten bunkern das feuer die
kampfhandlungen auf okinawa dauernd 82
tage
am ende wurden über 7000 marines getötet
und knapp 37.000 verwundet
die 32 der armee der japaner verlor über
100.000 mann
es wurden nur knapp 7000 gefangene
gemacht
unter der zivilbevölkerung gab es
unfassbare 100.000 tote im boden krieg
auf okinawa starben also insgesamt fast
eine viertelmillion menschen
von der küste original was spielt sich
derweil ein makabres todes ritual ab
dass einmal mehr zeigt wie eisern die
japaner ihr land verteidigen
eine beängstigende erfahrung der us
matrosen waren die selbstmord missionen
der japanischen kamikaze-piloten die
gegen amerikanische schiffe gerichtet
waren
kamikaze bedeutet so viel wie göttlicher
wind dieser soll die flotte des
mongolischen herrschers kublai khan
versenkt haben der begriff ist
aufgeladen mit heldentum aberglaube und
mythos und die jungen soldaten wurden
damit indoktriniert
durch das ausüben der selbstmord
angriffe warin ewige ehre sicher sie
opferten ihr leben für das japanische
kaiserreich
das ritual und die opferbereitschaft
lassen sich auch in brutalen zahlen
beschreiben
die verluste unter den japanischen
piloten stiegen auf 96 prozent die
flieger waren unerfahren und der sprit
knapp so dass die angehenden piloten
nicht mal richtig ausgebildet werden
konnten
ein kamikaze pilot musste nur ins
flugzeug steigen abheben in richtung
schiff steuern und hineinfliegen während
der drei monate ins schlacht um optimal
war versenkten
1465 kamikaze flieger 29 schiffe 120
werden beschädigt 9000 83 angehörige der
us navy werden verwundet oder sterben
wenn man die verluste der alliierten vor
der küste zu denen an land hinzuzählt
kommt man auf über 10.000 tote
zusammen mit den verwundeten und
vermissten sind es 53.000 mit den 36.000
die an einer kriegs la rose litten
steigt die zahl auf fast 90.000 und das
alles für eine insel die 100 km lang und
25 kilometer breit ist
der amerikanische general starb eine
schätzung in auftrag gibt mit welchen
eigenen verlusten bei einer invasion der
japanischen hauptinseln zu rechnen sei
lautet das ergebnis ungefähr
350.000 man
sie müssen sich unangenehmen fakten
stellen
einen monat nach der schlacht von
okinawa treffen sich churchill truman
und stalin im juni 1945 in potsdam um
über die nachkriegsordnung in europa zu
beraten
das war ein großes hin und her
manövrieren
war klar wer der neue feind war nämlich
stalin
deutschland ist nach der kapitulation
der wehrmacht in vier besatzungszonen
aufgeteilt worden so auch die hauptstadt
berlin die in der sowjetischen zone
liegt
die rote armee hat sich im kampf gegen
nazi-deutschland weit nach mittel- und
osteuropa vorgekämpft stalin will seinen
einflussbereich entsprechend festigen
die westalliierten sehen dies mit sorge
aber der zweite weltkrieg ist noch nicht
zu ende
der potsdamer konferenz hatte präsident
in einem ultimatum die bedingungslose
kapitulation der japaner gefordert und
mit völliger vernichtung gedroht sollten
sie weiterkämpfen truman wusste dass er
seit einem erfolgreichen test der tum
bombe in aller motto am 16 juli 1945
eine mächtige kriegswaffe in der
hinterhand hat
noch während der konferenz atomen zu
stalin ganz nebenbei dass die amerikaner
eine neuartige waffe hätten wovon dieser
durch seinen geheimdienst längst weiß
trotzdem bekräftigt stalin sein
versprechen dass er den westalliierten
auf der konferenz von jalta gegeben
hatte japan drei monate nach dem sieg
über deutschland anzugreifen noch
während er in potsdam wald gibt truman
den befehl zum abwurf der atombomben auf
japan
[Applaus]
und mord am morgen des 6 august 1945
sehen die menschen in hiroshima 3 b 29
bomber über der stadt
die einwohner von hiroshima dachten sie
seien gefeiert gegen bombardierungen
denn bis dahin waren sie von angriffen
der b 29 bomber verschont geblieben
[Musik]
die traurige wahrheit war das general
curtis mm3 japanischer städte ausgewählt
hatte und jetzt waren die bewohner von
hiroshima dran
die atombombe die von der enola gay auf
hiroshima abgeworfen wird legt die halbe
stadt in schutt und asche und tötet
70.000 menschen sofort in den folgenden
monaten sterben noch mehr zivilisten
[Musik]
denn die menschen starben an einer neuen
krankheit der strahlenkrankheit sie über
die zeit steht durch sie die anzahl der
todesopfer in hiroshima auf rund 140.000
doch die japaner wollen immer noch nicht
kapitulieren drei tage später werfen die
usa eine zweite bombe auf nagasaki ab
dort sterben 30.000 menschen sofort und
mehr als 73.000 an den folgen
[Applaus]
tags zuvor hatte moskau den japanern den
krieg erklärt über 1,5 millionen
sowjetische soldaten mit 5500 panzern
überwältigen die japanischen truppen in
der mandschurei sowie auf den
konferenzen von jalta und potsdam
besprochen
burkheiser hirohito forderte seine
minister dazu auf mit der us regierung
kontakt aufzunehmen um die bedingungen
einer kapitulation zu verhandeln als
hirohito in den 1920 er jahren den thron
bestiegen hatte wollte er pazifistisch
international und demokratisch regieren
wurde aber zur geisel eines militärisch
geprägten landes ich schaffte es nicht
sich dagegen aufzulehnen
erst gegen ende des krieges mit der
bedrohung durch die invasion der roten
armee durch hungersnot und die atombombe
kann er den militärführern endlich sagen
ihr atem unrecht und ich im recht es ist
zeit den krieg zu beenden
er besteht darauf am 14 august einer
radioansprache zu halten die
kapitulation japans bekannt zu geben
selbst jetzt weigern sich militärische
hardliner die niederlage einzugestehen
es gab immer noch einen harten kern von
offizieren die versuchten in den
kaiserpalast einzudringen um die
tonaufnahme der rede zu finden und zu
vernichten
sie dachten der kaiser sei von menschen
beeinflusst worden die nicht mehr an
einen sieg laufen wie sie selbst waren
immer noch überzeugt den krieg gewinnen
zu können
kaiser und sein kammerdiener mussten
sich vor ihnen verstecken es kam sogar
zum schusswechsel auf dem gelände des
kaiserpalastes als die aufständischen
versuchten die aufzeichnung zu finden
erst als kaiser treue soldaten sie
zurückschlagen konnten zwar die
aufgezeichnete ansprache in sicherheit
manche der aufständischen verübten
selbstmord haben die atombomben oder die
invasion der sowjets die japaner
verhandlungsbereit gemacht war es
überhaupt nötig die atombomben
abzuwerfen all das wird bis heute
diskutiert
wenn ich 1945 in der amerikanischen
regierung gewesen wäre hätte ich für den
abwurf der atombombe gestimmt
die japaner kämpften weiter und ich
glaube nicht dass sie bereit waren zu
kapitulieren
die hardliner im japanischen
oberkommando wollten weiter kämpfen
erst nagasaki veranlasste den kaiser
dazu einzugreifen
die amerikaner dachten wirklich dass sie
mit dem abwurf der atombombe den krieg
schnell beenden und zahlreichen
landsleuten das leben retten würden auf
der anderen seite wollten sie auch
unbedingt wissen ob diese neue
technologie funktioniert
1945 wussten nur wenige wie schrecklich
atomwaffen waren sie waren ja noch nie
eingesetzt wurden
für präsident truman ist die atombombe
doppelt nützlich als ass im ärmel gegen
stalin und als waffe gegen japan
[Musik]
man sollte bedenken dass brandbomben
mehr japaner getötet haben als die
atombomben von hiroshima und nagasaki
es ist leider in jedem krieg so dass
menschen erst einlenken wenn sie das
töten und sterben nicht mehr tragen von
einfach wollen das vorbei ist und die
japaner wollten nicht aufgeben
für mich geht es nicht um die frage
atombombe oder konventionelle waffen
sondern darum ob es überhaupt zu
rechtfertigen ist zivilisten zu
bombardieren
am zweiten september 1945 nimmt general
macarthur die kapitulation der japaner
auf dem schlachtschiff die uss missouri
in der bucht von tokio an der zweite
weltkrieg ist damit offiziell zu ende
die westalliierten stehen nun vor zwei
fragen erstens wie sollen sie mit der
noch alliierten zur wert union umgehen
und zweitens was machen sie mit
deutschland und seiner ns
hinterlassenschaft
im november einigen sich die alliierten
darauf führende nationalsozialisten
wegen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit in nürnberg vor ein
militärgericht zu stellen in der
internationalen militärgericht so
verhandelte so viele fälle wie
angeklagte auf die anklagebank platz für
vor prozessbeginn begeht einer der 24
angeklagten selbstmord ein anderer ist
verhandlungsunfähig die typische
verteidigung der hochrangige nazis bei
den nürnberger prozessen war ich habe
nur befehle ausgeführt
was das militär betrifft so liegen denn
alle ihren beweise vor dass die
wehrmacht von dem verbrechen wusste
kein park ist ein herrenhaus das in
nord-london während des zweiten
weltkriegs hütte britische geheimdienst
dort deutsche generäle fest trotz
kriegsgefangenschaft lebte sie hier in
relativen luxus wussten aber nicht dass
das gesamte gebäude verwandt war frauen
aus den transkriptom wird ersichtlich
dass die wehrmacht bei den
kriegsverbrechen mitgemacht hat sie war
teil der tötungsmaschinerie und des
holocaust
angeklagte wie zum beispiel
luftwaffenchef döring zeigte keinerlei
reue
andere wie albert speer wollten sich
dadurch retten dass sie sich für ihre
taten entschuldigten die rede ist an
zierte sich von hitler
von den in nürnberg angeklagten nazi
größen werden drei freigesprochen sie
behalten langjährige oder lebenslange
haftstrafen und 12 werden zum tode
verurteilt im verhältnis zum ausmaß der
begangenen verbrechen werden insgesamt
nur wenige deutsche zur verantwortung
gezogen
historic historiker gehen davon aus dass
bis zu 800.000 menschen für die
ermordung von juden verantwortlich waren
es 99 99 prozent von ihnen standen nie
vor gericht im westen in westdeutschland
wurde gegen rund 140000 verdächtige
ermittelt doch nur 164 wurden des mordes
für schuldig
164 menschen bei über sechs millionen
morden
das ist unglaublich
wenn man sich die prozesse an sieht ihn
aus deutschland und in österreich
durchgeführt wurden dann ist auch da die
anzahl an verurteilungen erschreckend
gericht
grund dafür ist unter anderem
politisches kalkül
ein hauptgrund war der beginn des kalten
krieges nun hat auf einmal die jagd auf
kommunisten oberste priorität
mit dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs war
das verhältnis zwischen den ehemaligen
verbündeten der anti-hitler-koalition
schnell abgekühlt
stalin ist einer der grössten sieger des
zweiten weltkriegs
1945 hatte er mehr land als 1939
traurigerweise schien der zweite
weltkrieg stalin und sein regime zu
rehabilitieren
jetzt ist klar der krieg hat ihn
millionen von menschenleben gekostet
aber er hat den kult um seine person
aufgefordert
er stellte den krieg später als seinen
persönlichen sie da mit beginn des
kalten krieges entstehen zwei lager
sozialismus gegen kapitalismus
ostblock gegen freie westliche welt als
sich der kalte krieg verschärft fällt es
den sowjets immer schwerer mit dem
anderen großen gewinner des zweiten
weltkriegs mitzuhalten
die vereinigten staaten waren nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg viel reicher und
mächtiger als davor
die usa werden nach dem krieg zum
inbegriff wirtschaftlicher stärke und
sicherheit
fast alle anderen beteiligten länder
lagen in trümmern und waren bankrott
der zweite weltkrieg kostete die
europäischen staaten schätzungsweise 9
158 milliarden us-dollar und zwang
großbritannien frankreich und
deutschland in die knie als sich der
eiserne vorhang senkt und europa in ost
und west teilt erkennt george marshall
ehemaliger us generalstabschef dass
etwas unternommen werden muss er wurde
nach fress genügte nicht dass die usa
stark waren europa musste auch stabil
sein und das ging nur wenn die
wirtschaft wieder auf die beine kam
der marshall entwickelte ein großzügiges
konjunkturprogramm das den am krieg
beteiligten ländern wieder zu wohlstand
verhelfen sollte deutschland
eingeschlossen hat er besaß die weise
voraussicht dass sich sollte deutschland
wirtschaftlich klein gehalten werden die
geschichte wiederholen könnte es so wie
es nach dem versailler vertrag am ende
des ersten weltkrieges passiert war
durch den marshall-plan erhalten 16
europäische staaten zwischen 1948 und 51
hilfszahlungen in einer höhe von
insgesamt 310 milliarden dollar
1,4 milliarden gehen an westdeutschland
und knapp 2,3 milliarden und frankreich
großbritannien erhält den größten teil
ein
strategischer gedanke war auch das
europa genug geld hatte um aufrichten
und als bollwerk gegen eine mögliche
bedrohung durch die sowjetunion
fungieren zu können
der marshall-plan ist nicht die einzige
hinterlassenschaft des zweiten
weltkriegs schon einige großartige
institutionen wurden gegründet die
vereinten nationen die nato und die eu
frankreich und deutschland sollten eine
so enge verbindung aufbauen dass sie nie
wieder krieg gegeneinander führen würden
1951 entstand die montanunion die
europäische gemeinschaft für kohle und
stahl das war ein zusammenschluss von
sechs ländern die mit diesen materialien
handelt
frankreich deutschland italien belgien
die niederlande und luxemburg
für die sechs länder die in westeuropa
am schlimmsten vom krieg betroffen waren
die rücken immer näher zusammen damit
sich ereignisse wie der erste und der
zweite weltkrieg niemals wiederholen
würden
wenn man eine solche handelsgemeinschaft
aufbaut oder gar einen staatenverbund
dann wird ein krieg immer
unwahrscheinlicher denn die länder sehen
sich dann nicht mehr als einzelstaaten
sondern eher als brüder und schwestern
max die franzosen die deutschen und die
niederländer waren es gewohnt dass
soldaten anderer länder auf ihren
straßen patrouillierten und was sie von
anderen nationen kontrolliert wurden da
haben die briten haben diese erfahrung
nie gemacht
wir haben ihre unabhängigkeit nie
verloren vielleicht wollen viele leute
sie deswegen auch heute nicht aufgeben
der wirtschaftliche aufschwung in der
nachkriegszeit verhilft vor allem einem
großen verlierer des krieges zu neuem
wohlstand
1945 zählte sich deutschland sicher
nicht zu den gewinnern aber es
entwickelte sich danach prächtig
vorrunde des schicksals hätte
deutschland den krieg nicht begonnen
hätte senat von 20 jahren auf
friedlichem weg die wirtschaftliche und
industrielle vormachtstellung in europa
heute ist deutschland ein florierender
demokratischer staat mit einer starken
wirtschaft
auch japan profitierte von der
nachkriegs allianz mit den amerikanern
und es gibt noch einen gewinner des
zweiten weltkriegs mao tse tung in china
als der japanische premierminister mao
tse tung 1972 in peking besuchte um sich
für die invasion in den dreißiger jahren
zu entschuldigen sagte mauer angeblich
sie müssen sich nicht entschuldigen wenn
es die invasion nicht gegeben hätte wäre
die kommunistische partei in china nie
an die macht gekommen
ob der sieg über japan ebnete mauer und
der kommunistischen bewegung in china
den weg um sich krank und den
nationalisten entgegenzustellen und vier
jahre später den bürgerkrieg zu gewinnen
auch wenn der zweite weltkrieg schon
acht jahrzehnte zurückliegt dass sich
die umstände die dazu geführt haben
genau zu studieren und sich zu erinnern
damit solches unheil sich nicht
wiederholt
einer der gründe dafür im zweiten
weltkrieg zu kämpfen war es die welt von
tyrannei und unterdrückung zu befreien
und liberalismus und demokratie zu
stärken
heute hat kaum jemand mehr vertrauen in
die politische elite und es gibt
befürchtungen dass erneut autoritäre
bewegungen entstehen können vor denen
wir uns in acht nehmen müssen
es ist immer einfach sich die
vergangenheit anzuschauen und zu sagen
damals war alles anders wir haben uns
weiterentwickelt aber tatsächlich hat
sich in der welt gar nicht so viel
geändert
wir müssen uns im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert darüber bewusst sein dass
der schatten dieser kriege immer noch
über uns hängt und so etwas nie wieder
geschehen darf das müssen wir den
menschen immer wieder ins gedächtnis
rufen sie müssen verstehen was damals
geschah um es nicht zu wiederholen wenn
es wieder zu einem weltkrieg kommt
werden die verluste viel höher sein als
im zweiten weltkrieg
[Musik]